welcome back everyone I just got back
from Vegas a few days ago and I'm sure
most of you know that I played a pretty
strong classical tournament in Vegas but
maybe what you didn't know is I also
played a blitz tournament it was a
Walter Brown Memorial Blitz part of the
Vegas chess festival and I actually
filmed all my games in the tournaments
and I want to share my very first game
of that tournament in this video and the
game features a Stafford Gambit and what
I'm gonna do is show the footage and
then just talk about my thoughts as a
footage place now I was playing a player
who I didn't recognize and I didn't
actually know her rating
until after the game her rating is about
20 50 feet a it's probably good that I
didn't know this because if I knew she
was this high rated maybe I would not
have played the Stafford Gambit but we
will see uh me delve into one of my
favorite openings I'll also say that I
was maybe like the 10th or 11th seed in
the tournament uh there are a lot of
strong Grand Masters playing Hans Neiman
was a top seed and then there was Ilya
niznik and version of kobian
but let's hop into this game okay we
shake hands and the game begins so E4 E5
F3 and I am going for the Stafford
and we see my opponent play pretty
quickly which kind of gave me a sense of
discomfort but of course I'm still in my
prep Bishop C5
and with this moment of hesitation I
realized my opponent probably isn't so
well prepared Bishop E2 is one of the
more common moves and I was debating
between Queen D4 and H5 but I do play
Queen D4
hitting F2 and after castling now I play
H5 now I want to play Knight G4 and set
up a lot of attacking ideas she plays D3
I played Knight G4
and now of course I'm hitting F2 and
there's really not too many ways for
white to defend here
the best move which I knew during the
game is Bishop takes G4
but it is hard to concede the bishop
pair
and there are some other moves as well
of course Queen E1 is a main alternative
so it's feeling good up uh more time
than I started with
almost up a minute and she does play
Queen E1
so defending F2 now the drawback of this
move is black is able to keep initiative
and during the game I was trying to
remember what I've studied before but I
do play Queen E5
hitting the pawn on each two threatening
made in one
well if white takes some Knight I take
back and then there's just a massive
attack so for this reason she plays Pawn
to G3
and I pretty quickly play Pawn to each
War so trying to get all the pieces
involved
Rook Knight and queen
after Bishop F4 Queen E7 there's still
some pressure against whites especially
with this Pawn tension
and I am having ideas I was trying to
calculate while my point was thinking I
was calculating ideas of taking King
takes and takes
and I wasn't entirely sure what white is
going to try here to defend
because there's just so much pressure
from so many different directions
really there's so many pieces
that contribute to Black's attack
so she takes the knights
I take back
do notice that we were playing with
non-weighted pieces so there were a few
moves where it was easy to just knock
pieces over and when this happens you
have to adjust them before uh completing
your move
so Bishop E3 was played
and now What's Happening Here is white
doesn't have a lights for Bishop and
with this structure light squares are
very weak on the king side so I was
trying to figure out how to effectively
take advantage of this
and there are perhaps a few candidate
moves but I decide for Bishop F3
dreaming of teleporting my queen to G2
and I'm not too far away
want to play Queen E6 and queen H3
now she takes a bishop
I take back I was actually calculating
this line because it's a natural
continuation for whites to now play the
move Queen E3 that I very quickly play
Queen H5 and the queen is so well placed
on H5 defending the bishop
and creating the battery with now the
queen and the rook and with upon tension
still remaining there's no way for white
to keep the H file closed and there's a
big threat of taking
and queen H2 checkmates
and we can see my opponent falling very
low on time
and yeah what to do for lights
how to defend
I was searching for defense but didn't
really see an effective one after Queen
F4 I take
and after Queen takes G3 Rook H6
and
yeah white is in big big trouble
The Rook is coming to G6
and what to do I was imagining Rook G6
Queen H3 and eventually getting the
mates anyway in addition to winning the
queen
time taking down light falling below 10
seconds and yeah white resigns
and it was a pretty
smooth game
of course White had chances to be much
better after the opening and I do want
to go back and just share basically what
my opponent should have done
not to allow this very dangerous attack
now Bishop E2 is considered a slight
mistake just because black can
essentially equalize after Knight takes
E4
now I didn't go for that line because H5
just offers more attacking ideas
and actually during the game I was very
much hoping for H3 and this walks into a
really cool trap Knight G4 and if it
takes takes then black is winning
because Queen E5 Queen H2 is a massive
threat so D3 Queen E5 and there's no
stopping checkmates like G3 it's made in
one
and there's a really cool line instead
of D3 let's say G3 I still play Queen E5
King G2 looks to defend because now if
Queen H5 there's Rook H1 but there's a
pretty scintillating tactic here another
Peace sacrifice Bishop takes F2
and uh White is just getting blown off
the board if Rook takes F2 now Queen H5
and there's no uh no stopping Queen H3
really and there's no Rook H1 so this
would be winning there's another funny
line of takes check here check here
Bishop E6 I've shown this before in many
videos but just goes to show the joy of
the standard what uh the potential traps
can lead to
so going back what my opponent should
have done in
this position after Knight G4 was take
and after takes Bishop F4 uh White's
actually holding on there'd be maybe
some chance to get initiative but the
engine gives almost plus one in uh
White's favor
um but going back even further I'll show
what I was most scared of and it's
actually a simple line in this position
uh one of the reasons why the Stafford
is not
a great opening is because white has a
move H3 here and this really puts a
hamper on Black's attacking chances
because there's no Knight G4
and um yeah the engine I think will give
like almost plus two yeah over plus two
for whites of course I would have tried
to fight but um I would not have looked
forward to playing this line I usually
play H5 but there's other moves there's
G5 with idea of G4 there's B5 B4 ideas
um sometimes Queen D4 will come in these
lines as well
so it could have been a much bigger
challenge if my opponents knew the um at
least one of the refutations
but it was a fun game hope you guys
enjoyed this one uh let me know if you
want to see more of my games from the
Vegas Blitz tournament I did play a few
very strong Grand Masters towards the
end of the tournament
so stay tuned for more and I'll see you
guys soon